[Música]
donald trump no se rinde son dos semanas
después que el demócrata joe biden
declaró la victoria a la elección
presidencial el mandatario todavía
parece buscar opciones para revertir el
resultado hoy se reunió con legisladores
republicanos del estado de michigan que
todavía deben certificar el resultado
mientras tanto georgia anunció tras un
reconteo de los votos que la victoria
este baile
el huracán y ahora que ya se disipó tras
dejar más de 40 fallecidos en colombia y
centroamérica ha hecho además que unos
200.000 habitantes de nicaragua honduras
y el salvador tengan que dormir en
albergues el presidente hondureño
declaró del estado de calamidad y pidió
ayuda internacional para reconstruir su
país
en el día internacional de los derechos
de los niños el fondo de la onu para la
infancia alertó sobre las repercusiones
de la pandemia a largo plazo en la vida
de toda una generación de menores a
medida que la situación amenaza con
causar daños irreversibles a la
educación la nutrición y el bienestar
global además recomendó que con las
medidas adecuadas es mejor mantener las
escuelas abiertas tenemos análisis en
esta emisión de noticias
muy buenas noches gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france 24 se hablan con
gusto saludarlos comenzamos a este
informativo en eeuu donde el presidente
de donald trump continúa su pulso por
revertir los resultados de las
elecciones estadounidenses tras alegar
durante semanas un fraude electoral el
mandatario se ha reunido con
legisladores del decisivo estado de
michigan mientras que el principal
funcionario electoral de georgia
certificó que los resultados electorales
que muestran a joe biden ganó las
elecciones presidenciales es
irreversible informe de natalia plaza
suárez
donald trump no se rinde dos semanas
después de que el candidato demócrata
joe biden celebrará su victoria en las
elecciones presidenciales el mandatario
aún intenta revertir los resultados
electorales del 3 de noviembre este
viernes trampa está reunido con los dos
líderes republicanos del congreso de
michigan una simple reunión de trabajo
según ellos esta no es una reunión de
promoción no habrá nadie la campaña allí
él se reúne habitualmente con
legisladores de todo el país pero el
encuentro se lleva a cabo cuando el
presidente busca convencer a los jueces
electorales de ese estado de no validar
los resultados electorales que dan la
victoria a job hay de tras ello algunas
fuentes apuntan a un plan de tron para
que el congreso estatal al fin el
presidente seleccione los delegados
electorales del estado entre tanto el
decisivo estado de georgia confirmó la
victoria del candidato demócrata tras un
reconteo de los votos
working al trabajar como ingeniero a lo
largo de mi vida he vivido bajo el
modelo de que los números no mienten
adif en amberes como secretario de
estado creo que los números que hemos
presentado hoy son correctos
los números reflejan el veredicto del
pueblo no una decisión de la oficina del
secretario de estado o de nuestras
cortes o de otras campañas quiero hacer
todo lo que pueda para construir la
confianza de los votantes en nuestro
sistema electoral
y ahora puedes solicitar un segundo
recuento tanto georgia como michigan son
dos estados claves de las elecciones ya
que cada uno otorga 16 votos electorales
del total de 270 necesarios para
convertir a uno de los dos candidatos en
el nuevo presidente de eeuu varias
personas fueron baleadas en un centro
comercial en wisconsin en eeuu no está
claro cuántas personas han recibido
disparos pero el alcalde de la ciudad de
guagua tous ha indicó que no se habrían
presentado víctimas mortales según
informes locales un hombre armado abrió
fuego en el mayfair mou en guagua tosa
ubicado a 11 kilómetros al norte de
milwaukee se cree que el sospechoso
sigue prófugo y los equipos swat están
buscándolo por el centro comercial y los
alrededores
la farmacéutica pfizer envió una
solicitud de la administración de
alimentos y medicamentos de eeuu para
que autorice el uso de su vacuna contra
el coronavirus como medida de emergencia
el anuncio era esperado desde hace
varios días atrás luego de la
publicación de los resultados del ensayo
clínico en marcha desde julio con 44 mil
voluntarios en varios países y según los
cuales en la vacuna tendría una eficacia
del 95 por ciento sin efectos
secundarios graves para el director
ejecutivo de facer hoy es un día
histórico y de celebración
protestas en varias ciudades de brasil
contra el brutal asesinato de un hombre
negro a manos de dos guardias de
seguridad en un supermercado un episodio
que han comparado con el del
estadounidense 'george floyd se trata de
joao alberto silveira freitas de 40 años
quien murió la noche del jueves tras
recibir golpes por parte de los
vigilantes de este supermercado en la
sureña ciudad de porto allegre las
brutales agresiones capturadas en fotos
y videos que fueron difundidas en las
redes sociales por su parte el
vicepresidente del país negó que se
trate de un caso de racismo y afirmó que
en brasil no existe la discriminación
racial
el presidente de honduras juan orlando
hernández afirmó que jamás el país se
había vivido un golpe tan fuerte de tres
fenómenos al tiempo la pandemia el
huracán eta y el huracán gota hernández
clamó por ayuda mundial para reconstruir
su país que aseguró pasa por una gran
calamidad por la devastación que dejaron
a su paso por centroamérica los potentes
huracanes eta
j honduras como otras naciones de la
región sufrió el embate de ambas
tormentas este mes con apenas una semana
de diferencia
a dos semanas de diferencia inundaciones
deslaves severos daños de
infraestructuras y viviendas al menos 91
muertos y decenas de miles de
damnificados en el país
escuchamos ahora lo que fueron parte de
las declaraciones del presidente
ante esta calamidad
los países industrializados sería
reconocieron que son participantes
la producción del cambio climático
tienen que atender a nuestros países
sino no hay manera
porque si no todos los años nos vamos a
seguir endeudando para estar resolviendo
cosas que producen el cambio climático
que no somos nosotros los responsables
también señaló que habrá transparencia
en las ayudas recolectadas pero los
damnificados y no permitirá que se
desvíen los fondos
y lo que queremos es un sistema de
buenas prácticas que se adopten en la
administración del poder ejecutivo por
ejemplo ya la secretaría de
transparencia emitió una resolución para
que sea obligatorio que el proceso de
licitación sea abierto y público a
través de los medios de comunicación
y usando también catálogo electrónico y
la isla colombiana de providencia frente
a la costa de nicaragua quedó destruida
el paso del huracán yo está que llego a
este territorio como categoría 5 se
llevó todo por delante su cerca de 6000
habitantes se vieron sus casas en sus
negocios en ruinas esperan ahora la
ayuda del gobierno para reconstruir nos
cuenta la noticia matías a redes
unas imágenes catastróficas
knight es uno de los muchos residentes
de la isla colombiana de providencia que
se han quedado sin hogar después de que
yo está arrasará con todo lo que estaba
en ti en la isla esta semana
uno se planea algo para tener una buena
vejez para que los niños estén bien se
fue la estabilidad de mis hijos la
estabilidad mía
esto es muy duro la verdad
casi toda la infraestructura de
providencia donde viven unas 6000
personas ha sido dañada o destruida
además dos personas murieron una sigue
desaparecida y varias quedaron heridas
desde bogotá salieron acciones llevando
más de 80 toneladas de asistencia
humanitaria como carpas quita
alimentarios y botellas de agua
el presidente colombiano iván duque en
su visita a providencia declaró que era
la primera vez que colombia era golpeada
por un huracán de categoría 5 el
mandatario decretó el estado de desastre
natural en el archipiélago una vez
hayamos completado la remoción de
escombros una vez hayamos completado la
limpieza empezamos con lo que denominado
el plan 100 100 días
máxima capacidad de trabajo para hacer
la mayor reconstrucción posible de la
extra isla de providencia unas
declaraciones que suscitaron vivas
críticas por parte de la oposición al
presidente colombiano se le acusa de
haber ignorado el aviso del centro
estadounidense de huracanes y de no
haber evacuado la isla y con motivo el
día mundial de los derechos de los niños
unicef advirtió en un informe que la
pandemia puede provocar impactos de no
retorno en educación salud nutrición y
el bienestar de los niños y niñas en la
región de américa latina y el caribe
ante esta situación unicef urge a los
gobiernos del sector privado
organizaciones sociales y sociedad en
general para velar por que los menores
puedan continuar aprendiendo y reducir
la brecha digital y también propiciar el
pronto regreso a las clases a las clases
presenciales bajo condiciones óptimas de
seguridad por cuenta de la pandemia
quiero saludar en este momento a
margaret sachs israel asesora regional
de educación de unicef para américa
latina
señora gracias por estar con nosotros y
también por su tiempo le pregunto como
la pandemia ha afectado el derecho a la
educación en nuestra región en américa
latina y el caribe
muchas gracias buenas noches en una
región que ya antes de la pandemia
estaba caracterizada por altos niveles
de desigualdad en términos de acceso a
la educación y los logros de aprendizaje
el cubil 19 ha contribuido a
profundizarlas por un lado el cierre
prolongado de las escuelas hace probable
en más de 3 millones de estudiantes
interrumpan definitivamente su
trayectoria educativa y no regresen a
las aulas tras la pandemia
por el otro lado el impacto de las
interrupciones escolares en los lugares
de aprendizaje corre el riesgo de ser
grave y duradero en particular para los
niños niñas en situación de
vulnerabilidad
ahora amargar detrás de estos grandes
discursos de los gobiernos de manera
concreta cómo podemos asegurar que los
niños regresen a las escuelas cuando
vuelvan a abrir
y así quería decir tienen una de las
prioridades para un izar son los niños y
niñas los más vulnerables y asegurar su
acceso a la educación y su aprendizaje
se requiere facilitar el regreso a la
escuela y la permanencia de esas niñas
niños y adolescentes incluso por ejemplo
mediante la eliminación de las barreras
financieras y de género
variables medidas no si esas medidas
podrían incluir asistencia por ejemplo
en efectivo y con cupones para lugares
vulnerables pero también y eso es
también muy importante requiere asegurar
que todos los niños niñas adolescentes
crean urán su aprendizaje en el nivel
adecuado en particular a pelos en riesgo
de abandono a través de programas de
educación de recuperación y apoyo
socio-emocional margaret gracias por su
tiempo por estar aquí con nosotros en
france 24 que tenga usted una feliz
resto de noche nosotros continuamos con
más información en el estudio el senado
mexicano ha aprobado una normativa que
regula el uso y la comercialización de
la marihuana ahora falta la aprobación
de los diputados y de lograr la
despenalización méxico se colocaría como
el tercer país después de uruguay y
canadá en regular el cannabis recreativo
méxico está el primer paso hacia la
legalización de la marihuana el senado
ha dado luz verde a la ley federal para
la regularización del cannabis que
todavía tendrá que pasar por la
aprobación de la cámara de diputados- de
seguir adelante se sumaría a uruguay y
canadá donde está despenalizada esta
propuesta permitiría el consumo
recreacional la creación de un órgano de
control federal y el cultivo propio
numerosos activistas se han pronunciado
en pro a la reforma legal esto nos daría
un gran impulso a nivel internacional
para posicionarnos como lo que somos la
industria principal de la cannabis en el
mundo
en noviembre de 2015 en la suprema corte
falló por primera vez a favor del uso
lúdico del estupefaciente desde entonces
el lente habría emitido cinco sentencias
similares pero fue en 2018 cuando se
activó el debate de la legalización y la
corte dio un plazo al congreso para
regular la los detractores de la ley
alegan que ésta fomentaría la
dependencia en menores y daría mayor
poder a los cárteles que tienen el
control mayoritario de la droga sin
embargo los consumidores defienden que
su prohibición va en contra del libre
desarrollo de la personalidad y el
proyecto de ley que han presentado hasta
ahorita no resuelve los temas de las
violaciones al derecho de libre
desarrollo de la personalidad en donde
es y esto es lo que se tiene que
reformar la planta se tiene que
despenalizar en lo que nosotros exigimos
cultivo libre posesión libre espacios
compartidos en igualdad y un trato digno
falta por ver cuál será el próximo paso
del gobierno de habló al respecto
y esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo en france 24 continúa con
nosotros para más actualizaciones de
noticias continúe con nosotros buena
noche y hasta pronto
[Música]
en un instante economía
france24 en español sigue